and then what happened I wasn't thinking
her room is connected with the bathroom
so he just went through the bathroom and
went through the second door yeah oh no
Meanwhile your foot's still on the front
door like I'm still here
we're this way he got it and he sees me
and I'm just like I'm like this and I'm
like he was just like I knew it and took
it out on her I didn't do anything did
that make you feel stronger because he
didn't attack you bro cause you know
what I would have been like you're gonna
hit her not me I'm not scared anymore I
opened the door and I was like this
you stepped over her you came back to me
like like pressing me hey bro this is
none of my business G like I ain't even
know she was even had like had to do and
he's all just like you know get the [ __ ]
out of here he's like coming to me just
like dude I'm just like don't even oh
[ __ ] she was like like because I was
leaving out the door I I went like that
to her straight up I was out of there
oh wait